hello i'm jim hong kao distinguished
scientist and vice president at
microsoft research i'm also leading the
deep learning group here
thank you for joining us today to share
our research progress on deep learning
and the large-scale ai
as today's presentation have
demonstrated
we have made good progress in creating
deployable large-scale ai models using
deep learning to drive innovative
real-world applications in language
vision and beyond
and microsoft researchers are looking to
develop new ways of enhancing ai
capabilities beyond the scale
from building ai that draws information
from multiple channels of input
to creating progressively
better
more efficient measures for model
training and deployment
however
as we look to the horizon of how we hope
ai will be able to complement people's
skills and abilities
there are several huddles that we must
overcome to make ai models
more adaptable
reliable and safe
when navigating
even more complex
real world scenarios
so
what should we expect the next
generation of ai models to achieve
first
large-scale ai models
need to be more efficient both in terms
of training and then deploying them in
various settings
many state-of-the-art portraying
language models for example
use a
monolithic model architecture that are
trained on unstructured data using
stochastic gradient design
making model training and serving
inefficient and expensive
second
these models need to become more
flexible in their ability to adapt
even though
per training is resource intensive
large-scale models today have limited
ability to transfer this learning
to new tasks
and their adaptation often requires
large amounts of tasks specifically
labeled data
which is not always available
a third key area for improvement is
knowledge in coding and reasoning
language models train on unstructured
texts
often miss important pieces of explicit
real-world knowledge
such as those stored in knowledge basis
this can lead to a disconnect
between user goals and the intents and
the models perceptual of the world
although the progress of large-scale ai
in the last few years
is impressive
incremental progress will not be
enough
to create trustworthy air capability of
the skill flexibility and complexity
needed
for new applications in the cloud or on
the age
both areas evolving quickly alongside
the ai
we need to take a big leap forward in
model efficiency
with that nostril go in mind microsoft
research
aims to move ai forward
with groundbreaking gains in efficiency
of model training
serving adaptation and reasoning in the
next decade
do this our vision includes four
different areas
we are exploring experience grounded
learning an alternative
learning paradigm that combines
reinforcement learning and supervisor
learning and unifies model centric and
data-centric approach to ai
this new way of learning allows
ar agents to learn quickly and adapt as
they interact with changing environments
we are also exploring a modular model
architecture
instead of building bigger
monolithic ai models that are expensive
to train and serve
we strive to make am models more modular
by jointly optimizing model structure
and model parameters for example by
neural architecture search
such models will be more efficient to
train serve and adapt to new tasks
another area of opportunity lies in
developing large-scale air models that
can better represent and encode
structured knowledge
avoiding the need to learn everything
from scratch
this could not only boost modern
efficiency but also unlock the ability
for ai to accomplish more knowledge
intensive tasks and scenarios
finally
there have been many advances in
language models but understanding and
processing information in all its forms
is important to advancing ai
including understanding sounds or images
in conjunction with text
we see the importance of drawing from
multiple senses to gain knowledge every
day in our lives
this experience shows why
establishing new methods for multiple
modeling is crucial for creating the ai
of the future
if would like to learn more about these
research areas
or are interested in opportunities at
microsoft research feel free to contact
my microsoft colleagues and myself